>> In today's video,
we're going to show you
how to make a food dehydrator.
It can be used to make
a number of tasty snacks,
and it's built from a cardboard box,
a light bulb, and a small fan.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
To start off with the build
of this food dehydrator,
we're going to want a cardboard box,
some aluminum foil,
and some strong tape.
If you have some of this metal tape,
that will work the best.
But if you don't have any of this,
other strong tape
like duct tape will work as well.
There's no specific size or shape
of cardboard box that you need,
but I have this one because
it fits really well with the racks
that we'll fit inside of it.
This box used to hold reams of paper,
and if you don't have one lying around,
I went to a store that sells paper,
and they sold this box to me for a dollar.
This is a 250 watt heat lamp bulb,
and this is an old
cooling fan from a computer.
If you don't have one,
you can buy a heat bulb
at most hardware stores
for about 10 bucks.
Sometimes they have
a red color to them,
but they'll work just
the same as this one.
Here's the basic idea of
how our food dehydrator will work.
Both of these will be inside our box,
which would be lined with foil.
The heat from the lamp will be
circulated by the air from the fan,
and that will swirl slowly around
the food that we're dehydrating,
drying it out.
The first step will be to use
our aluminum foil and our tape
to line the inside of the box
and the inside of the lid with the foil,
shiny side out.
[Music]
There we go.
The inside of our box in our lid
is now completely lined with foil.
And you can see how shiny
and reflective it is in there.
That's really going
to help the heat bounce around
and not get absorbed by
the cardboard of the box.
Now it's time to move on
to adding the fan and the heat lamp.
This fan came out of an old computer,
and runs on 12 volt DC current.
To power this 12 volt DC fan,
I went to the local thrift shop,
and just bought a used power supply.
This power supply has
an output of 12 volts DC current.
So it should run our fan just perfectly.
Before we permanently
solder anything together,
let's just do a quick test
to see if our power supply is working.
I've got it plugged in right now.
I think this will only work
one direction with the wires.
Well, it's working that direction.
Definitely getting a breeze off of that.
So now we can solder those together
to make the connection permanent.
[Music]
Our fan is wired and ready to go.
So now we need to install it in the box.
And we're actually going
to keep the box oriented like this.
Our lid isn't going to work as a lid,
but instead is going to work as a door.
So we want our fan installed
into the side of the box.
And since this is going to be the bottom,
we'll put the fan right here.
I've got it elevated up
from the edge just a little bit
to avoid the overlapping
piece of cardboard here.
It doesn't really matter
exactly where you put it,
as long as it's on about
the bottom half of the box.
[Music]
With the hole cut to the fan,
it may be a good idea
to take a little bit more tape
and tape down these edges.
If you've cut the hole to the right size,
the fan should fit nicely into place.
Now that we've got the fan installed,
we want to install the heat lamp
on the other side of the box.
To power the heat lamp,
I have this chord that's
just a chord on one side
and a light bulb socket on the other.
And this would work
if we didn't want an on or off switch,
or the ability to choose
how much power came out of this bulb.
But I want both of those things.
I want to be able to turn off the light,
and I want to be able to turn it down.
So here I have
a rotating dimmer switch.
We're going to install this
into the middle of the power cord.
These two wires are
the positive and negative lines,
and we'll have one of the wires
running through our power cord,
connect into one side and out the other.
I've cut the power cord to the light bulb
and exposed the ends of the two wires
so we can now solder them
in line with the light switch.
We'll solder the
two black wires back together,
and then we'll take
the white wire and have that split,
so it connects to the red wire
on one side of light switch
and the black wire on the other.
[Music]
Looks like it's working to me.
Now, before I solder anything in place,
we do need to run this wire
through the other wall of this box.
Otherwise, we would have to have
a really big hole for the light bulb
to fit in and out.
So let's cut a hole just large enough
for this cord to fit
through the wall of the box.
[Music]
Beautiful.
Heat lamp is now on a dimmable circuit.
And we can turn it off.
There's a very good chance
that we could use the heat lamp
in our box just like this,
and nothing would
ever be a problem with it.
But just to be sure we don't
have too much heat passing
from the bulb through
the foil into the cardboard,
let's use a little bit
of a hanger to build a stand
that will hold our
bulb up off of the foils,
just a little bit.
[Music]
This sort of double m shape
does a good job of holding the bulb
off of the bottom of the box,
which should allow
circulation all around it
and prevent any overheating.
The dehydrator is coming along nicely.
And at this point,
what it needs is somewhere to put
the food that's being dehydrated.
These cooling racks I got at Walmart
for about $3.50 each were great.
These racks are one of
the reasons I got this size of box.
They fit really nicely in with just
a little bit of extra space to spare.
And there's enough
clearance above the light bulb
that we can easily fit two racks in here,
one on top of the other.
To be able to hold
the racks right where we need
and still be able to take them in and out
of our dehydrator whenever we want,
let's use a couple of dowels
running across our whole dehydrator.
[Music]
I'll put one rack about this high,
and the other one,
maybe an inch and half below that.
[Music]
As you can see, these racks do extend
slightly beyond the front of this box.
But we don't have
to put this lid on all the way.
It overlaps with the main body of the box,
3 inches normally,
and we just don't need it to do that.
As long as it's covering the openings,
it's going to work just fine.
To help the lid stay in place
approximately where we want it,
let's use a little bit of tape
as a sort of hinge on one side of the box.
[Music]
Our dehydrator is just about ready to use.
There's just a couple more
small improvements we can make.
First off, we want that fan
to actually be circulating the air,
and not just be spinning in dead space.
So let's cut several small
holes into the top of our box.
This will help the
air come in one side,
travel up past the food,
carrying away any excess moisture,
and out the top.
[Music]
The dehydrator would
work great just as it is,
but to contain our switch
and to keep it from flopping around,
and just lying wherever on the table,
let's grab a scrap of cardboard
and build a box that it can sit on
to hold all of the excess cord,
And so we just have a nice place
where we always know
the switch is going to be.
[Music]
At this point,
our dehydrator box is complete.
The whole thing is lined with foil.
We have a fan,
we have a light that's on a dimmer switch,
and all we need to do is
pick our food and put it in.
With the front of the box closed,
I can feel the air coming up
out of the holes
we've cut into the top.
And once we turn on the light,
the air inside will start heating up.
To make our dehydrator look just
a little bit less like a cardboard box,
we're going to hit it
with a layer of paint.
[Music]
Obviously, this level of decoration
is not necessary to make it work.
It will dehydrate your food
just fine without any changes to it,
even if it just looks
like a cardboard box.
Really quick,
let's take a look at
some of the things
that we can make with
our Dehydro-tron 5000.
I've got three different things here
that I've dehydrated at home
and it worked really well.
I have some pineapple
which I covered in sugar
before putting in the dehydrator.
Some apple slices,
which I just sliced in pieces.
Put on the rack
and then left it overnight.
And I have some beef jerky.
There are tons of good recipes
for making beef jerky at home
using a dehydrator.
It's fast, it's easier,
and it's way cheaper
than buying it at the store.
[Music]
Wishing there was
still more for you to see?
Well, you're in luck.
That little box up the top
will transport you directly to our last video.
Go check it out.
The box in the bottom
will show you what
YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
This bomb in the center will
subscribe to our channel
so you never have to miss another video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.